Speaker 1: And speaking of investigations,
what's happening over in the state of Texas?
Texas Attorney General Ken Paxton on Trump's
orders has been investigating voter fraud in the
state of Texas, right? Even though Trump handily
won the state of Texas, he still wanted an audit
of some of the areas that Joe Biden won. Much like
he's wanted here in the state of Florida, and I'll
get more to that in just a moment. But in Texas,
they finally caved and said, All right, all right,
we're going to investigate because you want us
to investigate. And it was recently announced
that Ken Paxton's office spent $2.2 million this
year investigating voter fraud. 20000 lawyer hours
investigating voter fraud. And the state managed
to close three cases. In 2021, $2.2 million.
Three cases, 20000 hours of work. That's
what Texas was able to do this year, and
it's actually quite remarkable because last year,
Texas closed 17 cases related to voter fraud. So
that would seem to indicate to me that since there
were fewer this year, obviously the 2020 election
in Texas was far more secure than their previous
election, the midterm elections in 2018. Three
cases, that's it. You're talking about a little
over $700000 per case. Nearly 7000 hours per case.
Is what the state of Texas spent in terms of
time and money to close these three cases?
The fact of the matter is
that voter fraud is not common
in the United States. And it sure as heck is never
been common enough. To overthrow the results of
an election, to overturn the election, to
swing an election one way or the other.
But Trump is still so just bent on trying to prove
that even in the areas Biden won in a state that
Trump won by a lot. That somehow it still wasn't
that much Trump can't stand losing anything,
any county, no matter how blue it
is, he still wants it to be red.
Because any person in this country voting
for Joe Biden instead of Donald Trump
is an affront to Donald Trump. And unfortunately,
we have these Republican governors out there, like
Greg Abbott in Texas and of course, Ron DeSantis
over here in Florida, who are more than willing to
spend whatever it takes to make a mockery of their
entire state, even though they've both assured
us that, hey, things are totally cool here, we
didn't have any fraud. When Trump asked them to do
something, they're dang sure going to do it, even
if it means spending 20000 hours and $2.2 million
to close three cases of possible voter fraud, and
let's let's remember that's closing three cases.
That doesn't mean three people were found to
have committed voter fraud. It means those
three cases are over with either they found
the evidence and they charged the individuals
or they couldn't find any evidence. And they
just ended it. This report doesn't say which
was which we do know there's at least one case
that they did find, but the other two. May have
been completely wasted, all the money. Thousands
of hours of people's work for absolutely nothing.